vous avez des papiers monsieur moi j'ai
pas de papiers je descends pas avec des
papiers dans des endroitsù je peux le
perdre t vous faites des photocopies
quand on va retrouver votre cadavre en
état de putréfaction avancé ça sera
vachement difficile d'identifier vos
[Musique]
enfs dans le royaume obscur et tortueux
des catacombes le commandant sarat
patrouille il est pas tolérable que des
gens puissent se promener à 20 m sous
terre en dessous le métro en dessous les
égouts en totale impunité et en
contravention avec la loi sans que la
police y mette son
nez on peut pas se permettre d'occulter
la visite d'une galerie parce qu'elle
est inondée il faut absolument aller
voir au bout on ne sait pas du tout ce
qui peut se passer on sait pas du tout
ce qu' peut y avoir au bout donc il nous
appartient dans le cas de la visite
générale de de ces carrières de vérifier
s'il n'y a pas quelque chose au bout qui
puisse vous
[Musique]
intéresser un fil d'Ariane c'est
vraisomablement un fil qui a été déposé
par des des gens qui qui descendaient
pour la première fois à l'intérieur du
réseau ça évite évidemment de se
perdre tu V à gauche ouais il a des tas
de gens qui s'aventurent dans ce réseau
et qui parfois arrive à se perdre
pendant plusieurs heures voire des fois
plusieurs jours ce qui nécessite
l'intervention des services de sécurité
pompiers police pour aller les
chercher 285 km de galerie court sous
Paris alors pour retrouver la sortie
chacun a sa méthode le fil d'Arian est
un peu démodé le catafil préfère les
flèches bariolées voilà l'ancêtre des
catafil a été retrouvé ici en
1804 il s'était perdu le 3 novembre 1793
on était en pleine Terreur il s'agissait
du portier du valde grâce il a tourné il
a aé et puis très rapidement il a dû
mourir de faim de soif de froid et puis
il éta retrouvé là 11 ans après par une
brigade topographique comment on l'
reconnu 11 ans plus tard au clés qu'il
portait après sa boucle de ceinture
était les clés du valde
grâce pas grand monde ce soir hein non
c'est bien calme pour l'instant
peut-être peu t qui a eu une grande fête
le 3 novembre 1993 pour fêter le
bicentenaire de la disparition de
philiip berasper où à cette occasion on
avait interpellé 250 personnes à
l'intérieur du réseau de carrière on se
montre de préférence peu répressif peu
répressif mais surtout extrêmement
préventif on met les gens au courant des
dangers qu'ils en courent à l'intérieur
c'est très
important ah c'est effectivement des
châtières assez étroites enfin bon les
jeunes il passent il y a pas de raison
qu'on y passe
pas hop
là apparemment ça s'est pas très bien
arrangé dans cet abri dans ce ce bkerer
c'est toujours aussi
sale on se trouve ici dans des salles
dépendantes de l'abri de défense passive
qui avait été construit par les
Allemands donc qui sont fréquentés
manifestement par les visiteurs
clandestin puisqu'on trouve enchassé
dans le mur des des spit destiné à
accrocher des hamacs pour pouvoir
dormir on va prendre par
là tiens regarde là tu vois on est
vraiment au centre de l'AB là au centre
de l'abri de l'abri allemand on avait
tout le tableau de commande électrique
avec les lignes téléphoniques qui
arrivaient et toute l'installation
électrique permettait d'allumer
d'éteindre là derrière toi tu avais un
comment dirais-je un
[Musique]
puit alors on entre dans le sas ici on
est ici dans le sas puisque finalement
nous avons là un escalier qui
communiquait avec le Jin du
Luxembourg
ah il y a eu du monde il y a pas
longtemps les bougies sont encore là les
bouteilles on est arrivé un peu trop
tard
ou un peu trop
tôt il est certain que la police qui
descend à l'intérieur est un rempart un
rempart contre les exactions plus graves
qui peuvent être commises comme des vols
commis avec violence des viols puisque
ça s passé dans les années 80 d'où la
création de cette équipe qui descend
c'est la seule équipe de policiers qui
descend en carrière pour contrôler et
verbaliser les Allemands avaient déjà
trouvé le système les flèches de couleur
Saint-Michel NotreDame Bonapart interof
sorti la flèche de
couleur tiens Marc ou cel tu me prends
ça
merci encore
une tu viens on faire un tour voir un
peu la fontaine des
char
ça fait moment que je
all la fontaine se trouve sous le
quartier SaintMichel dans une des
premières carrières creusé sous la
capitalees galeries du 9e siècle c'est
là queon a extrait la pierre le plâtre
et le gravier nécessaire à la
construction du vieux
Paris aujourd'hui on appelle à carrièr
les
catacombes
au départ il y avait des carrières s
terrain et il faudra attendre finalement
la fin du 18e siècle pour que l'on
décide de vider enfin les cimetière par
Waso parisien qui était au nombre de 300
à l'intérieur de Paris éit une
pestilence épouvantable un foyer
épidémique sans nom une véritable
horreur il a donc fallu s'en débarrasser
pour des raisons tout à fait sanitaires
et où mettre ces ossems qui se chiffra
entre 5 et 6 millions de personnes et
quelqu'un a pensé immédiatement et si on
mettait ça dans les carrières
souterraines du côté de la tombissoire à
l'époque après d'enfer rocher qui était
la campagne et donc on a décidé de
consacrer une portion de carrière
souterrainee d'un km 700 pour en faire
un ossware
municipal par analogie avec celle de Rob
on a appelé ça les catacombes mais ça
n'a rien à voir ça n'est pas un lieu de
sépulture c'est un dépositoire en fait
d'osem ça
[Musique]
unosire quelques mètres plus haut les
entrailles de Paris bouillonnent on a
misétr mat des
égs il y a quelque chose en dessous je
te DISI ah
le bateau van retient l'eau et la libère
en un jet puissant qui pousse les
déchets solides vers un bassin de
[Applaudissements]
récupération sur la
ch
le plus impressionnant je crois que
c'est le noir et le le bruit de l'eau
être 4 5 he comme ça dans le noir c'est
pas c'est pas évident au début arrête
arrête habitue parce que les collègues
sont là pour pour vous aider quoi il y a
quand même pas mal de danger on est
alors faut tout le temps être un petit
peu solidaire les uns des autres c
laeule c'est bien qu' un copain qui le
rame trottoir égûs sont étroits au
centre l'eau tiède atteint 2 m de
profondeur tomber dans cette rivière
souillée c'est risqué la noyade surtout
le matin lorsque 2 millions de Parisiens
prennent leur douche et tirent la chasse
d'eau au même moment des fois on trouve
des choses c'est incroyable il avait
aussi bien des bougies de voiture que de
la fonce j'ai trouvé une poussette de
gosse on a ça devant devant le
bateau il paraî qu' a plein de bestioles
dans les égou on dit qu'il a des
crocodiles c'est vrai on a trouvé une
fois un petit crocodile et une fois un
serpent mais c'était au cas de la
Mégisserie ça donc c'est un petit peu
normal ils sont tombés dans dans une
chute et puis sinon ce qu'il y a c'est
des rat et ici il y a pas de rat il y a
trop d'eau les seuls qu'il y a ils sont
morts ils sont noyés maillon après
maillon les égoutiers curent les 2300 km
d'égoutt 2300 km c'est comme aller de
Paris à Istanbul à la barre de leur
vaisseau rouillés ils n'ont pas assez
d'une vie de travail pour couvrir une
telle distance mon père était aux éout
mon père mon grand-père après il y a mon
frère qui est rentré mon autre frère qui
est rentré mon beau frère mon autre beau
frère ça fait qu'on est quand même pas
mal au égout maintenant et c'est souvent
des familles les égoutiers très souvent
oui quand il y en a un il y en a 10 on
choisit pas les égouts pour les égouts
on dit pas tiens je vais prendre les
égouts parce que c'est un bon métier
c'est c'est faux parce que aimer
travailler en souterrain dans le noir
tout le temps et dans les mauvaises
odeurs faut pas dire que ça soit bien
intéressant on passe beaucoup de temps
ensemble dans un endroit
fermé donc ça ressert les liens quoi
chacun connaît un petit peu la vie de
l'autre donc au bout d'un moment quand
ça fait longtemps qu'on se
connaît ça fait de l'amitié quoi ça as
été dansé hier tu as des entrées gratis
chez Michou
toi bon on y va là c'est l'heure de la
p la première chose quand on sort de l'
goû première chose à quoi on pense c'est
de prendre une bonne
douche un coup de savon rouge et un coup
de savon
blanc si vous vouz malad on pe pas les
attraper facilement nous ce que n Une
vaccine on est immunisé pour
[Musique]
tout il a perdu son dentier arrivé fait
excusez-moi ah ouais il arrête
pas de sastiquer les mains et tout
regarde cétait son enti
est mignon là est très bien un petit
coup d'éponge un M de
lu Arian la bille elle est
pompe il est 9h Alain et Pierre prennent
leur service
en jargon de la RATP on les appelle les
parcoureurs ils oscultent les voies
chaque infiltration chaque boulon cassé
et signaler en circulant on regarde bien
les attaches c'est-à-dire ces choses là
sont les attaches du rail une attache
qui est cassé donc c'est le même
signalement que l'autre quce que nous
avons vu
là attache cassé on tache cassé mais tu
vois ils sont pas ils sont pas nul faire
ouais s'il y en a plusieurs consécutive
c'est grave on laisse pas d'ailleurs on
remplace tout de suite nous-même
attention à nous on se range ça va rou
cont le M contre contre le M c'est une
rou
carrée c'estàd qu'il a un plat sur le
roulement exactement de la roue et le
plat on
l'entend
c'est pas une roue c'est plusieurs roues
carré là c'est plusieurs roues carré
facilement en train de ber ou après on
sétonne que les sur cassent bah ouais
nous notre oreille on est capable
d'analyser le bruit il y a des joints
qui sont dangereux parce qu'il font un
bruit anormal alors qu'un joint à côté
fera plus de bruit sera moins dangereux
c'est une
analyseit
al al toujours par làin parce que
j'attends pour voir si le train arrive
toujours touours toujourours on a déjà
eu une expérience tous les deux qui est
pas si vieille que ça hein tu te
souviens Pierro j'ai relevé la tête j'ai
vu le train qui arrivait sur nous on
était vraiment très près du train j'ai
juste eu le temps de de de me lever et
et de pousser de pousser mon collègue
contre le mur on s'est rangé devant lui
50 cm c'est dangereux votre métier alors
très dangereux
salut les trains frôent les parcoureurs
à 60 km he c'est indispensable pour la
détection des problèmes à l'oreille la
sécurité des voyageurs dépend de ces
hommes bon ce soir on va descendre par
ARAG santé notre accès
habituel on vaer faire un petit tour
dans la galerie des promotions ensuite
on va redescendre tranquillement vers le
sud puisquon est vendredi donc
normalement il devrait y avoir du
monde on regarder ça sur le plan merci
bien bon tout le monde connaît donc on
entre là comme d'habitude on dégingole
dans la galerie des promotions au retour
on prendra Saint-Jacques on reprend
direction du sud puis on va all jeter un
coup d'œil par là on jeter un coup d'œil
dans ces salles là enfin bon on va
essayer de de barrer le sud ce
soir les bar de fer porter
aussi le commandant sarat dirige le
commissariat de la Goutte d'Or un
quartier sensible plusieurs fois par
mois il troque le Ki contre le casque
Léo et il descend travailler sous le
pavé
parisien les catafiles ont surnommé le
commandant sarat et sa brigade les
catafliques cabinet direct galerie des
promos
et on progresse en silence c'est de la
chasse ce
soir la visite des carrières est
interdite depuis
1955 la majorité des accès sont murés
pourtant chaque année 15000 personnes
trouvent une entrée et viennent
déambuler à 10 m sous
terre la brigade atteint la rue
Saint-Jacques au niveau de la galerie
des promotions c'est là que sont baptisé
les nouvelles recrues de l'École des
Mines avec chaque année une marine
différente oh ça sent le sucre en
poudre mais qui est-ce qui fait ça
catafil catafil les habitués qui veulent
finalement éloigner de leur réseau les
les gens qui ne sont pas habitués qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de descendre à
l'intérieur on fait de la fumée ça fait
peur vous allez avoir
peur c'est pas laine de
courir
bonsoir bonsoir c'est quoi votre
sur No
No qu'estce que vous faites
restauration ça s cassé la gueule donc
profit pour un peu faire un truc de
proprés sil plît
merci vre
adresse adresse ouais bah ici jusquà qu
comp rest il y en a encore neuf de ses
petites
sœurs finalement ces gens-là qu'est-ce
qu'ils font là-dedans ils descendent ils
se promènent ils font des petites fêtes
bon c'est pas trop grave pendant qu'ils
font ça en dessous ils sont pas en train
de faire des bêtises en surface si on
veut du jour au lendemain interdire
totalement la pénétration et l'accès
dans les carrières c'est facile on peut
le faire vous laiss continuer alors donc
on tolère amusez-vous bien bonne soirée
bonne journée je sais pas si vous avez
encore conscience du jour de la nuit
depuis mardi franchement son ouais
j'imagine
bien franchement c'est vive le biorthme
et vivre le Seigneur
bus merci
ouais
attention au bout de ferraille qui vont
prendre du blafond les rapports que nous
avons maintenant avec les gens qui
fréquente ses carrières sont assez
ambigu on n pas du tout les mêmes
rapports que les policiers de surface
peuvent avoir avec leurs contevenant ils
nous considèrent un peu comme des leurs
il nous considère un petit peu comme des
catafiles nous aussi une pièce
d'identité petit ah il
faut petit pétard ça va mais 40 g quand
même ça fait beaucoup on parle le même
langage que lorsquil nous cite un lie
par une appellationticulière on sait
exactement où c'est on sait exactement
ce que ça veut dire on connait leur
surnom on connait bien cette population
pourquoi vous descendez ici dans les
catacombes il y a que là qu'on peut être
à peu près
tranquille vous descendez souvent
non au moins deux ou trois fois par an
et vous avez déjà participé à des
grosses fates ici non non non nous on
cherche une petite salle à l'aise on
s'installe est bien quoi et vous
piquequez pique voilà voilà on est comm
Mme prenant on s'aventure pas donc
n'importe où on raconte beaucoup de
choses mais il se passe peu de choses en
grande partie ce sont des gens qui
descendent pour se dépayser il
recherchent l'aventure il se promèneent
c'est un labyrinthe actuellement on
recrée des labyrinthes on plante du maïs
on fait des labyrinthes et les gens se
promènent à l'intérieur pour essayer de
retrouver la sortie c'est peut-être ce
qui cherche ici vous allez nous
présenter une piè
d'identité cé s'il vous plaît êes tous
ensemble là group
séparé
avec non bon ça c'est une famille çaen
une autre qui c'est qui connait li c'est
vous
apparemment on vient faire un petit peu
d'histoire parce que l'histoire de Paris
se retrouve dans ses sous-sols et et
voilà je suis venue pour la première
fois je trouve ça super
quoi plus et tout vous avez des papiers
moi j'ai pas de papiers je descends pas
avec des papiers dans des endroit je
peux le perdre faites des photocopies
quand on retrouver votre cadavre en état
de putréfaction avancé ça sera vachement
difficileidentifier vos enfants
profession suis
é mais pourquoi vous prenez les
téléphones des gens comme ça bah pour
nous appeler
là on descend mardi soir c'est pas la
peine le problème est simple je met où
le téléphone tu là on est
perpétuellement embêté par des gens qui
se perdent ou des gens qui signalent des
gens perdus première chose que l'on va
faire avant de déclencher le plan qui
nécessite quand même 180 personnes et
d'envoyer des chiens et le hasazard à
l'intérieur et en plus de cela rien ne
passe là-dedans la radio ne passe pas le
téléphone l'alpha page rien ne passe
donc il faut quand même qu'on prenne
quelques assurances avant et les
assurances ça va être de vérifier auprès
de tous les gens qui ont l'habitude de
descendre avec la personne sois-disant
disparue si vraiment la personne est
descendue et dans 9k sur 10 bah la
personne soit elle est ressortie soit
elle est pas descendue alors ça évite de
mobiliser des gens en pleine nuit pour
rien du tout c'est car bah oui monsieur
parce que la police aussi a le droit de
dormir la
nuit voilà je ne vous ferai même pas le
sermon voyez parce que je l'entendais il
m dit il va nous dire ceci va nous dire
cela et ben nime pas tant pis pour vous
vous l'aurez pas c'est bien fait vous
mourrez d'altospirose dans d'atrocce
souffrance on est tous vaccinés
laospirose est une maladie transmise par
l'urine des rats et puis si on y prête
pas garde ma fois c'est mortel quand
même dans C% des cas alors si vous av
vous fréquentez souvent ce site
faitesvous vacciner on y va
bonneirée
leptpyose tout ce qu'on voit dessus
c'est ce qu'on appelle les flottants les
bouteilles plastique les polystyrè et ça
extrait en même temps
que regarde a un N làdessous il fait une
belle maison
sontureessous tri la ferra le plastique
l'eau elle elle passe épuration et
8090%puration les égoutiers ne passe pas
plus de 5 he enfermé dans les égou le
tau d'humidité atteint des records et
les gaz dégagés par la fermentation sera
dangereux respirer trop
longtemps ce soir le train de travaux
dépose les ouvriers à
70 hommes vont uvrer toute la nuit ce
sont les forçats du rail ils forment une
immense chaîne leurs gestes sont répétés
à l'infini ils avancent sans jamais voir
le bout du
tunnel beaucoup de ces ouvriers
travailleront sous terre jusqu'à ce que
toutes les voies du métro soit changé le
chantier doit durer 17
ans la star de la nuit c'est elle la
dégarnisseuse les ouvriers s'agitent
avec d'il autour de cette reine de
ferraille personne ne parle rien ne peut
couvrir le bruit de la
machine V pour les machines quoi en
fait monde on
[Musique]
est
commentant
combiann fait 10
ans
R il pour 50 service hein
fatoiin mon petit alaron trop belle mon
ouillette au au quoi déjà au Derb de la
garigue la garigue tu fait plaisir et là
quelle heure il est là et là il est 1h30
ouais c'est bon à 4h tout va bien on est
bé à 4h 4h30 c'est bon on finir à 5h
comme tant mieux
la mor de finir à 6h du matin c'estis
qu'on est ma poule alors ça cuit tout ça
ça mijotte ça mijotte fais ça avec amour
pour 4 He ça va être bon c'est bon alors
c'est un P ça pour nous c'est un vrai
père heureusement qu'il est là oh
l'ambiance de nuit c'est
spécial part on est un peu plus
solidaire les uns les autres combien
d'années comme ça dans le tunnel de nuit
bah ça me fera 24 ans c'est pas long non
non B voyez comment voulez-vous que ça
soit long
ch la nuit a été dure pour les ouvriers
du rail et ce fut l'écatombe chez les
grillon de bon matin l'association de
défense du grillon descend à
Saint-Ambroise à la recherche de
survivant
oh quelle
catastrophe onentend plus rien c'est
quand même fou
quoi en av y en avait ou je m'en
souviens bien
ils ont changé les pierres du balast il
y a eu des
sacrific merci la RATP voilà le
silence le silence dans le métro on va
en mettre de cux on va mettre quel 4 ou
5 pour voir
si j'étais en chercher d'autres à la
Samaritaine on va mettre des mâles pour
l'ambiance et puis des femelles pour la
procréation
voilà vous allez le mettre à manger ah
oui faut leur donner à manger c'est
extrêmement important qu'à Paris on
entend des grillons dans le métro on est
la seule ville dans laquelle il y a des
grillons dans le métro
voilà je pense que là ils en on pour un
moment un peu de salade et 10 grillons
ça peut en faire combien en de mois des
millions